as if the crisis at the southern border
isn't bad enough squad member rashida
talib wants to take away
resources yes the far left democrat now
calling to defund
key federal agencies that help secure
the border and stem the flow of people
trying to enter the u.s illegally don't
believe me watch this
we must eliminate funding for our cpb
ice and their parent organization dhs
these agencies are inept uh to humanely
guiding
migrants through our immigration system
and further continue
instead they further continue to
terrorize migrant communities
republican senator tom cotton of
arkansas serves on the senate armed
services
uh judiciary and intelligence committees
and senator i just want you to listen to
one
other bit of sound from the
congresswoman because
she is trying to say that there are a
lot of people
there in washington as members of
congress that agree with her watch
the new members of congress are coming
with full force and pushing back against
this idea around
you know they rename uh this kind of
militarization or targeting
in a very inhumane way of our immigrant
neighbors it is
the same thing which is targeting
communities of color
in a way that is uh to me
very much violates uh you know human
rights
let's get your take on this senator
well dana unfortunately i think she's
right a lot of democrats do support
those radical views they want to defund
the police
they want to turn america into a
sanctuary country for
all illegal aliens from around the world
and now that logic is being extended to
our border patrol
and immigrations and custom enforcement
even all of dhs
i mean it'd be interesting to me if
rashida talib would explain exactly who
she thinks should be excluded from our
country when they show up at our border
irrespective of our laws or who in
america should be deported
i mean i don't know maybe her answer
would be conservatives or republicans or
anyone who voted for donald trump last
year but it seems like beyond that
rashida talib and most democrats think
that we should have totally
open borders and that anyone should be
able to come into this country that is a
recipe
for disaster you joined some other of
your colleagues
there on the senate side and sending a
letter to the attorney general
merrick garland asking about this open
borders question
here's mark bronovich from the attorney
general of arizona he was talking about
the situation at the border as he sees
it
the bide administration is making a
choice between migrants and americans
and they're telling the wrong people to
stay home they literally are trying to
shut down our economy
and i keep emphasizing to folks the
biggest health crisis
facing our country today is the biden
administration
because we may have three vaccines for
covet but there's no cure for stupid
and what the bible administration is
doing is just plain dumb
do you think that you'll be able to get
the attention of the attorney general
well this crisis is about to get a lot
worse dana it is the result of joe
biden's rhetoric and his policies first
he promised open borders in the campaign
all those migrants heard it when i was
at the border a few months ago i spoke
to several of them
and asked them why they came they all
gave some answer like joe biden or i
could get in now
second he reversed a lot of highly
effective policies most notably the
remaining mexico policy that
required migrants seeking asylum to stay
in mexico not to come the country and
live here
so they could uh for years where they
had their claims adjudicated
but now we're about to have a situation
where the democrats are going to pursue
amnesty in their coming budget bill this
is the word we've been getting over the
last couple weeks the democrats want to
include a massive amnesty
in that legislation that will simply act
as a bigger magnet for more illegal
immigration
into this country is that something they
want to try to do under that
reconciliation bill where
they would only need democrats
yeah that's exactly right dana's they
know that republicans are never going to
support some kind of massive
amnesty certainly with our border
totally open but bernie sanders and
chuck schumer and nancy pelosi and joe
biden's administration
are actively working behind closed doors
right now to try to include
an amnesty in that budget bill that's
something i'm going to fight
to the bitter end to stop because we do
not need
a single new illegal alien come in this
country when we're
already at a generational high level
i'm going to pay attention that because
if they can do that on reconciliation i
think that would probably get a lot of
attention one last thing
so apparently there's a bunch of
progressives that are sending a letter
to the administration warning them
not to be tough on china because that
could hurt
the fight against climate change as if
china was participating
in trying to help us in that regard
anyway
yeah that letter sounds like chinese
propaganda dana you know the chinese
even have a word for this
baozu they call it translates loosely
white liberal
people who are only concerned about
things like immigration and the
environment and who are willing to
sacrifice american jobs
and america's prosperity willing to look
the other way to genocide against
china's own people
all for some hope that china might one
day reduce its emissions
from its factories we need to crack down
on china
they unleashed a pandemic on the world
they've been cheating america's workers
for decades
it's time to lower the boom on the
chinese communist party not to look the
other way
in hopes of climate change promises that
are never going to come to pass
senator quite a value add this morning
learning a new word in chinese bozu
i won't forget it thank you